I'll be meeting with an endocrinologist concerning a spot on my thyroid that was shown to be
cancerous three years ago and now a new spot has been seen at a PET scan. What are some questions
or tests that I can ask for with this doctor? I want to avoid the removal of my thyroid.
Well, I would ask the questions like how big is this spot? Can we keep an eye on it
and do another test in three months if they're solely going as a PET scan for
saying that this is another cancerous spot? Are they going to play in doing a biopsy?
What's the what's the plan of attack with this? Can you see the spot on an ultrasound? Can you see
the spot on a CT? Can you see the spot on an MRI? How big is this how big is the tuberous area
that they think is cancer? All those kind of questions. I would also run some tuber marker tests
to see if there's any other tests that are going to show, give you some objective data on what's
going on. Again, it's like anything else, you know, ever want to just rely on one test to make
a life-changing decision.